[Musique]
nous sommes
le 5 août
on m'appelle pour me dire Madame
vous allez recevoir le Prix d'excellence
du président de la République ou la
valorisation des compétences féminines
mais surtout
à la base de l'ancrage du concept de
l'égalité des chances entre les hommes
et les femmes en Côte d'Ivoire
le lendemain
je reçois encore
elle t'appelle tu me dis madame demain
vous serez décoré dans leur national en
moins de deux jours j'ai eu deux prix de
toute la gloire revienne à Dieu
mais non je n'ai pas eu le temps de
vraiment savourer cet
héritage que j'étais en train de laisser
à l'humanité quand on m'appelle
du ministère de la Fonction publique
parce que je suis fonctionnelle
d'origine pour me dire
madame
vous êtes en train
d'être radié de la fonction publique de
Côte d'Ivoire
comment je peux être primé et puis être
à dire
j'ai pris mon courage à deux mains je
suis à le ministère de la Fonction
publique j'ai demandé à avoir le
directeur de cabinet et quand je l'ai vu
il m'a dit que tu m'as vu lui-même
d'abord il dit félicitations madame pour
tout ce que vous faites vraiment je suis
heureuse vous faites la fierté de la
Côte d'Ivoire vous avez fait l'héritage
de la Côte d'Ivoire partout en tout cas
bravo je le regardais parce qu'il savait
pas pourquoi je venais
j'ai dit il me dit asseyez-vous j'ai dit
monsieur je suis sur la liste de ce que
vous voulez rater qui dit comment ça
et il me dit mais qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé c'est là que je vais me souvenir
qu'en 2011 j'avais été appelé par une
autre autorité pour être directeur de
cabinet c'est-à-dire être dans un bureau
avoir tous les avantages possibles et
bien sûr les ressources mais en même
temps j'avais une vision j'avais envie
d'aider la communauté j'avais envie de
travailler vous avez entendu ce que la
femme a dit de travailler pour l'égalité
des chances entre les hommes et les
femmes parce que c'est de ça que la Côte
d'Ivoire avait besoin et j'ai choisi
d'aller sur le terrain c'est ce qui m'a
valu cela vous savez ce qu'il m'a dit il
dit Madame
votre travail a parlé pour vous vous ne
serez jamais radié de la fonction
publique et vous irez croyez moi
d'élévation à l'élévation parce que vous
avez choisi l'amour du prochain vous
savez choisir d'aider les autres c'est
comme ça que je me suis en sortie alors
on vous l'a déjà dit je suis fragile
quoi s'il Yao conseil spécial du
Président de la République de Côte
d'Ivoire chargée et question d'égalité
des chances entre les hommes et les
femmes et je suis également la seule
femme titulaire de chair UNESCO en Côte
d'Ivoire j'ai parcouru plusieurs pays
dans le monde pour dire ce que je sais
sur le genre et les qualités des chances
et je coordonne le compétium j'enseigne
aussi dans les universités et faites
beaucoup de conférences internationales
mais ce que je voulais dire aujourd'hui
c'est que ma vie n'a pas été long fleuve
tranquille à 4 ans
je dis bien 4 ans
j'ai quitté ma famille pour me retrouver
chez ma tante
on était nombreux d'abord on a une
famille de 27 personnes je savais pas
pourquoi j'étais chez ma tante
elle m'inscrit à l'école primaire
au CP1 je deviens première du ma classe
et ma tante était tellement heureuse
qu'elle me met au dos en disant ceci
merci Seigneur mon orpheline est premier
de sa classe
j'ai dit mais qui est Ophélie je n'ai
pas perdu mon père ni ma mère
de quoi elle parle mais je n'avais que 6
ans
je continue j'arrive
au CM2
alors pour remplir les fiches d'examen
pour la première fois
l'instituteur nous donne les nos
extraits de naissance
je regarde kouassier croiser autant
Kouassi koffi-folis
et puis je vois mes Koffi à moi j'ai
appelé l'instituteur je dis monsieur je
n'ai pas mon extrait ma mère s'appelle
Jeanne Charles je ne peux pas remplir
cette fiche je commence à pleurer mais
dis mademoiselle si c'est votre prénom
et votre nom si vous ne remplissez pas
vous n'allez pas avoir votre examen
j'étais contraint de remplir je venais
de me rendre compte de tout ce que
j'avais entendu au CPA que j'ai perdu
l'aide de plus cher de ma vie
[Musique]
je t'apprête à tout donner pour voir son
visage malheureusement je l'avais pas et
à travers toutes les femmes que je vois
ici en Côte d'Ivoire et dans le mot
monde entier pour moi ce sont mes mamans
et les jeunes filles voici l'image de ma
mère qui m'a été donnée mais plus tard
quand j'étais en terminale heureusement
pour moi que à la place de ce ma tante
m'avait inscrite à la catéchèse vous
savez comment on fait ce aussi m2 et
j'ai connu quelqu'un qui me disait je
t'aime ma fille je serai toujours avec
toi tous les jours de ma vie je serai
avec toi et il m'a conduit vers sa mère
la Vierge Marie j'ai nommé Jésus Christ
de Nazareth quand je suis avec lui je
suis en paix parce qu'il est le prince
de la Paix et c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé à constituer mon caractère la
foi en un Dieu fort et puissant la foi
en mon prochain
la foi en ce que je fais c'est vrai j'ai
perdu une lettre cher ma mère vous voyez
sa photo mais personne ne veut m'arrêter
sur ce que je vais faire j'ai continué
j'ai eu les bacs et c'est là que le papa
me montre la photo pour la première fois
je lui ai dit papa elle est mode de quoi
il me dit d'une grossesse esta utérine
je dis ok comme je viens d'avoir le bac
D moi je veux faire la médecine pour
pouvoir soigner ces femmes qui meurt en
couche en Afrique malheureusement ou
heureusement pour ce que je suis devenu
en m'envoyait en histoire et géographie
et dès que j'ai fini mon premier centre
c'était le Lycée Sainte-Marie de Cocody
j'ai vu des jeunes filles brillantes
des jeunes filles qui savaient ce
qu'elle voulait mais quand je regarde
dans la société comme la dame le disait
je ne voyais pas des femmes compétentes
à certains niveaux j'ai vu qu'il y avait
un problème à ce niveau je commençais à
les aider à les accompagner celles qui
étaient un peu dans la dévravation
aujourd'hui elle se sentir mais pendant
que je faisais cela que j'étais sur le
terrain il y a une maman qui m'a
remarqué elle a été nommée ministre de
la Famille elle m'a dit tu as trop
travaillé pour les jeunes filles
viennent travailler pour les femmes en
milieu rural je suis partie j'ai vu
encore qu'il y avait la misère au niveau
de ces femmes les femmes se réveillent à
4h du matin elles vont puiser de l'eau
en plus de l'eau insalu pour toute la
famille je me suis dit
c'était le moment de les aider mais
j'avais pas d'âme je savais pas quoi
faire et un jour mon patron monsieur
cocoper à son âme il avait réuni des
hommes et des femmes pour qu'on aille
sur le terrain et quand on est arrivé
sur le terrain il a dit mesdames prenez
la machine prenez les instruments
motorisés et aller travailler dans les
plantations et il y a une qui s'élevait
la dit Monsieur coco n'oubliez pas que
nous sommes des femmes ça c'est pas
notre rôle c'est pour les hommes et leur
a dit oui vous êtes des femmes parce que
vous avez des seins parce que vous
pouvez faire des enfants nous pourrons
pas en faire mais en dehors de cela nous
sommes des partenaires ce que les hommes
peuvent faire les femmes aussi peuvent
le faire j'ai dit patron ça c'est que la
force il me dit c'est l'approche de
l'égalité des champs Jésus voilà je
viens de trouver ce qui va faire ma
vision ce qui va la clé pour pouvoir
aider l'humanité pour laisser un aide à
l'humanité mais je me suis pas arrêté là
la formation je suis à l'heure en
Belgique j'ai appris au Japon en Israël
et vous savez ce que j'ai vu je me suis
rendue compte que cette approche dont on
parle tant dans le monde le genre
l'égalité des gens ça varie des pays à
un autre des continents à une autre
parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes cultures
on n'a pas les mêmes stéréotypes on
appelle les mêmes blocages je dis je
vais construire pour l'Afrique je vais
construire pour le monde et j'ai
commencé à travailler la première des
choses c'était en milieu rural j'ai
présenté un projet pour impliquer
simplement comme la dame le disait les
femmes et les hommes dans la gestion de
l'eau potable en milieu rural pour qu'il
y ait la pérennisation de l'eau quand
j'ai présenté ce projet devant 63 pays
réunis en France à Cannes plus de 2000
personnes vous savez ce qui s'est passé
la première des sociétés standing
ovation madame Yao la deuxième des
choses c'était de me donner un prix
d'excellence un prix du symposium et la
troisième des choses ils m'ont dit on
vous fait titulaire de une escroc qui
est réservé initialement aux professeur
titulaire d'université vous êtes dans un
ministère on vous donne parce que vous
méritez cela vous venez de laisser
quelque chose comme héritage à
l'humanité mais je ne me suis pas arrêté
là quand je suis venu
je vais travailler pour aller plus loin
j'ai permis à la Côte d'Ivoire d'avoir
la première direction de l'égalité de la
promotion du genre qui aujourd'hui
installé un peu partout dans les
militaires quand le président de la
République est venu il dit je veux avoir
des femmes à tous les niveaux je dis
Président on va vous proposer un
programme qu'on appelle compendium des
compétences féminines de Côte d'Ivoire
et qui a déjà entendu parler du
compétition heureusement voilà voilà
c'est un programme simplement qui vise à
renforcer la visibilité la participation
le leadership des femmes dans la gestion
des affaires publiques et privés c'est
un programme qui veut fournir des
informations créer une base de données
et quand une jeune fille ne sait pas où
aller pour chercher de l'emploi il faut
qu'on puisse la trouver directement ça
vise aussi à identifier les secteurs
comme la dame le dit où il y a pas de
femme c'est pas possible les hommes et
les femmes je vous les dis peuvent
travailler ensemble ça existe également
à mettre les femmes en réseau et ce
compétium a permis s'il vous plaît à des
femmes qui vendent sur les marchés
niveau CP2 de devenir député au
Parlement
ivoirien
c'est compétium a permis à des femmes
qui étaient entrepreneur parce qu'elles
ont été visibles elles ont eu leur plus
gros marché à des jeunes filles qu'on ne
connaissait pas qu'on n'a jamais vu mais
parce qu'elles sont dans notre base et
ils ont été opté par des entreprises
aujourd'hui elles sont responsables mais
le monde entier nous a reconnu on a été
fait meilleur programme africains de
valorisation des compétences hémistes
c'est-à-dire que tout le monde doit
venir apprendre ici en Côte d'Ivoire
on a été fait pour grand modèle par la
francophonie on a été fait buzz
pratiques par l'UNESCO et aujourd'hui
nous sommes prêts à aider tous les pays
africains à avoir leurs compétition
parce que c'est une stratégie que nous
avons
pour laisser un héritage à l'humanité
en dehors de cela
nous avons aussi je sais pas si vous
voyez bien
créez pour les décideurs vous savez
toutes les décisions viennent de là-haut
donc on a créé ce qu'on appelle
l'ingénierie du genre pour former les
résultats pour impacter la population
pour qu'on ait un monde juste dans
lequel les femmes et les hommes
bénéficient des mêmes opportunités
je ne me suis pas arrêté là parce que
les hommes veulent être formés mais j'ai
eu beaucoup de difficultés si je ne vous
dis pas parce que j'ai été ministre
parce que je suis conseiller spécial les
difficultés que j'ai eu c'est comme si
je ne vous avais pas dit la vérité j'ai
souffert dans mon foyer j'ai souffert
parce que en devenant leader j'avais
tendance à délaisser ma famille j'avais
tendance à faire tellement pour les
populations que mon mari a commencé à
prendre un coup et notre foyer a
commencé à battre de l'aide on a failli
divorcer on était sur le bord du divorce
quand mon oncle m'a appelé nous appeller
pour me dire ma fille tu as appelé à
être leader
si un leader c'est le kit c'est celui
qui donne l'exemple c'est un modèle pour
les autres tu parles d'unité de famille
de paix si tu n'es pas capable de garder
ton foyer quel modèle tu vas donner aux
femmes et mon mari et moi c'est assis on
a compris que l'essentiel c'était la
famille c'était l'unité et on a plus
sauvé notre famille qui est là qui comme
le dit est-il belle famille aujourd'hui
et
avant de finir mon propos je vais vous
dire ce que j'ai laissé de plus grand à
l'humanité
vous savez je parle souvent aux femmes
dieu merci il y a beaucoup de femmes du
compétium qui sont les enlever la main
mais un jour je me suis retrouvé à
l'ivoire avec des jeunes et dès que j'ai
fini de parler vous les connaissez il
faut tout en groupe ils sont venus vers
moi Madame la Ministre est-ce que vous
savez que quand vous vous taisez une
minute ce sont beaucoup de jeunes que
vous laissez dans les ténèbres je dis
avant donc je dois parler 24 heures sur
24 et pour ne pas le faire j'ai décidé
d'écrire un livre un livre impactant
inspirant un livre qui motive qui
éveillent la conscience on a vendu
5000 exemplaires en moins de 3 mois et
ce livre là c'est le secret d'une
aventure celle qu'on attendait pas au
sommet ici en 15 minutes je ne peux pas
tout vous dire mais dans ce livre qui
est vendu ici qui est vendu même sur
Amazon pour ceux qui ne sont pas ici en
Côte d'Ivoire vous avez tout de A à Z
sur mes échecs mes souffrances mais
victoire jusqu'à devenir la seule femme
titulaire vous savez tout et ce que je
voulais dire pour finir
vous voulez des leaders c'est sûrement
je ne savais pas que j'avais dit j'ai
jamais fait beaucoup de leadership
j'étais sur le terrain en train de
travailler quand on m'a fait leader en
étant titulaire parce que c'est une
distinction mondiale qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait quand j'ai des difficultés je pense
à l'amour du prochain je pense à l'amour
qui est plus fort que tout ce qui est
bruit dehors qui peut m'arrêter
quand je suis en souffrance je prends ça
ma vision à mon but et je me dis que
c'est plus fort que les résistances que
je trouverai dehors et je m'approche à
cela et comme je vous ai dit c'est Dieu
qui a conduit toute ma vie et je sais je
crois que en lui rien n'est impossible
et j'irai de voir en gloire je vous
remercie